I want to continue in volume two beginning at June the 21st, 1899. Jesus says, "For
love of you, I will not leave Corrato." Since Jesus was not coming, Louisa kept
thinking, "Who knows whether Jesus will not come any more, leaving me in abandonment?"
And she said, "I would say nothing but come, my beloved come." And then all of a
sudden he came and he told me, "I will not leave you, I will never abandon you."
So let me give you a number of scriptures for that and these will have to be
repeated over and over and over again. Sam 27 verse 9, Joshua 1-5, Hebrews 13-5
and John 14-18. "You two," he said, "come, come to me." Immediately I ran to place
myself in his arms and while I was like this he continued, "Not only will I not
leave you, but for love of you, I will not leave Corrato either." In other words,
the town is totally protected because of her relationship with Jesus. Then almost
without realizing he's in one instant he disappeared. I remained with a yearning
for him more than before and I kept saying, "What have you done to me? How is
it so quickly you have gone away from me without even saying goodbye?" And while
I was pouring out my pain, the image of the baby Jesus which I have near me seemed
to become alive and every now and then he would put out his head from within the
glass bell to see what I was doing. There was a statue of the infant Jesus near
her bed and it had a glass covering over it so it seemed to her that the statue
came alive in order to encourage her. I said to him, "It shows that you are too
impertinent." Now, impertinent is not a correct word there. God can never be
impertinent and we consider the word very negative. So let's use an innocuous word,
"too naughty" and that you want to behave like a child. I feel I'm going mad
with pain because you're not coming and you are there playing. Well then play
because I'll have patience, she says, so this is the desperation of someone in
pain. So June the 22nd, 1899, Louisa won't let Jesus sleep. This morning my
sweet Jesus wanted to continue to play his little games with me. He would place
his hands on my face and the act of wanting to caress me but as he was
about to do it he would disappear. Now what he's trying to do is increase her
love for him, increase her desire for him, increase her faith but she can't see
this at this particular time. She also can't see of course that he's with her
all the time and she's demanding to see him in a way that is totally off the
richter scale for everybody else. Then he would come again, she said, he would
stretch out his arms around my neck in the act of wanting to hug me but as I
stretched out my arms to hug him he would escape me like a flash and I
wouldn't find him. Who can say the pains of my heart? While my heart was swimming
in this sea of immense grief to the point of feeling life abandoning me, our
blessed mother came carrying a child in her arms. We hugged the three of us
together, mother, son, and I. So I would have time to say to him, my Lord Jesus, it
seems to me that you have withdrawn your grace from me. And he said silly, silly
little one that you are. How could you say I have withdrawn my grace when I am
within you? What is my grace if not myself? Now you remember in volume one he
said I am grace, I am faith, I am hope, I am love. So that's why he's telling her
that she's silly because she's acting according to feelings, not according to
facts. So Louisa said she remained more confused than before, seeing that I was
unable to speak and that in those two words I had uttered I had spoken nothing
but nonsense. Afterwards the Queen, mother disappeared and Jesus seemed to
enclose himself in my interior and there he remained. So he has told her I will
never leave you because she's living a very high state of union with him and
of course he's there all the time. Today then during the meditation he made
himself seen sleeping inside of me. I was looking at him. Do you remember St.
Mark's Gospel in chapter 4? Jesus asleep in the boat and then the terrible storm
came and the apostles acted as if they didn't need Jesus until they couldn't
handle the storm and was only then they called upon him. So Jesus was asleep. I
was looking at him, Louisa said delighting in his beautiful face but without
waking him up. Content with at least seeing him when in one instant the
beautiful Queen mother came again she took him from within my heart moving him all
over hurriedly we would say shaking him up so that he would wake up. She placed
him in my arms and blessed mother said don't let him sleep because if he does
you'll see what happens. A thunderstorm was being prepared. Half asleep the baby
stretched out his little hands around my neck and clasping me he said my mama my
mama let me sleep and Louisa said no no no my beautiful one I am not the one who
doesn't want you to sleep. It is our blessed mother mama that doesn't want it
and I pray you to content her. It is certain that nothing can be denied to a
mother and besides to that mother. After I kept him awake for a little while he
disappeared and so at end if you read the writings of St. Therese one of the
things she says is that Jesus slept in her little boat and she used to say to him
unlike the apostles I won't wake you up I will let you sleep and I will trust
that my boat won't go down in the storm because you're in it. Now what is
happening here is actually different from that because blessed mother is
telling Louisa that if Jesus goes into this sleep state as she's calling it
that that means that justice will take over and Louisa needs to be active in
terms of intercession to mitigate chastisements. So June the 23rd 1899
Louisa sees the confessor together with Jesus. After I listened to Holy Mass and
received communion my loving Jesus made himself seen within my heart and then I
felt I was going outside of myself but without Jesus. Now if you go into
an out-of-the-body experience it's very dangerous if not with the Lord. I saw my
confessor and since he told me our Lord will come after communion and you will
pray to him for me as I saw my confessor I said to him father you told me that
Jesus was going to come but he hasn't come he said to me it's because you don't
know how to look for him. This is why you say he has not come look well he's in
your interior. That's one Corinthians 3 16. No you not that you are the temple
of the living God and God dwells in you. So Louisa said I went looking within me
and I saw the feet of Jesus which had come out from my interior. Immediately I
grabbed them with my hand and I pulled Jesus out. I hugged all of him and in
seeing him with the crown of thorns on he said I removed it from him and I placed
it in the hand of the confessor telling him to drive it into my head. Now in
messages before now she would put the crown on her own head without saying
anything to anybody and so the confessor did put the crown on her head but no as
hard as he tried he could not manage to make even one thorn penetrate and Louisa
said to him do it harder don't be afraid that I might suffer very much
because as you see Jesus is here and gives me strength. So that's Philippians 4
13 I can do all things in Christ who gives me the strength but as much as the
priest tried it all turned out impossible. Therefore he said to me I'm not strong
enough for this. It is into bones that these thorns must penetrate and I don't
have the strength to do it. Now really he's talking about spiritual
strengths. He would have the physical strength but it would probably kill her. So
Louisa said I turned to my sweet Jesus saying you see how Father does not know
how to put it on do it yourself a little bit. So Jesus stretched out his hands and
in one instant he made all those thorns penetrate into my head to my
unspeakable pain and contentment and contentment means that now that she's
carrying the crown of thorns she will be able to get Jesus to mitigate some of
the chastisements. So put Hebrews 12 to there. After this the confessor and I
together Louisa said prayed to Jesus that he would pour his bitterness into
me so as to spare people so many scourges which he is pouring over them as he
seemed to do today since Hale was ready to come down not too far from us and the
Lord to condescend to our prayers did pour a small little bit. Now this means
that divine justice does have its way. Louisa's prayers and sufferings could
mitigate the chastisements a little bit but then Louisa is only one human being
and we're talking about the sins of the country and of the world. Moreover since
I continue to see the confessor I began to pray to Jesus for him saying to him
my good and dear Jesus I pray you to give grace to my confessor and to make him
all yours according to your heart. Now in previous messages she has also asked
that the Lord would bring him to sanctity and to give him corporal health as well
so I want to give you Acts 13-22 there. You've seen how he cooperated both in
relieving your head from the thorns and in having you pour. If he could not
manage to drive the thorns into my head it wasn't for the purpose of not
relieving you nor was it his will because he did not have enough strength to do it
so here's Louisa making excuses for him. Therefore because of this you must
answer him so tell me my soul and only good will you make him well both in soul
and in body. Now notice the soul is more important than the body. Jesus would hear
me but would not answer me. I would pray him with gracious solicitude saying this
morning I will not leave you nor will I stop praying if you do not give me your
word that you grant what I ask. Now remember Luke 18 verses 1 to 10 the
widow and the unjust judge the widow absolutely kept persevering until she
got what she wanted but also in Luke chapter 11 Jesus teaches us about prayer
and also tells us to persevere. So Louisa perseveres but Jesus wouldn't say a
word. Then all of a sudden we found ourselves surrounded by people they
seemed to be sitting around a table eating and there was also my portion
Jesus told me my daughter I am hungry and Louisa said I give you my portion
aren't you happy and Jesus said yes but I don't want to be seen and Louisa said
well then I'll pretend that I take it for myself and without letting others see
I'll give it to you and so we did. After a little while standing up and drawing
his lips near to my face Jesus began to play something like the sound of a
trumpet. Now the Hebrew word for trumpet is the shofar S-H-O-F-A-R in phonetics it
means the ram's horn and the trumpet was usually sounded as a warning to the
people. So I want to give you a revelation 6 16. All those people turned pale and
they trembled you see in other words they understood the shofar as a warning
saying among themselves what is this what is this now we're going to die and I
said to Jesus Lord my Jesus what are you doing how is this up until now you did
not want to be seen and now you start playing the trumpet be quiet be quiet
don't make people scared don't you see how they're all frightened and Jesus
said well this is nothing yet what will happen when all of a sudden I will play
even louder they will be caught with such fear that many will actually lose
their lives now in Luke 21 26 we're told that men would die of fear when they
saw what was menacing the world. Louisa said my adorable Jesus what are you
saying you always go there that is to justice and chastisement you want to do
justice but no mercy mercy on your people I pray so Jesus assumed his sweet and
benign look and I continuing to see the confessor began to importune him
again and Jesus told me I will make your confessor like a grafted tree in which
the old tree can no longer be recognized either in soul or in body and as a pledge
of this I have placed you in his hands as a victim soul now you need to add the
words soul there so that he may take advantage of it in other words if he
really does what the Lord wants him to do as Louisa's guide he himself will be
sanctified so it won't just be Louisa growing in holiness so June the 25th
1899 three spiritual joys of faith this morning Jesus continued to make himself
seen every now and then sharing a little bit of his sufferings with me and
sometimes the confessor appeared with him since he had told me to pray for
certain needs of his in seeing him together with the Lord I began to pray
Jesus to grant what the priest wanted and while I was praying all goodness
Jesus turned to the confessor and said to him I want faith to inundate you
everywhere just like those boats inundated with the waters of the sea and
since I myself am faith which is what he taught us in volume one you would be
inundated with me who possesses everything and can do everything and
gives freely to those who trust in me and without your thinking of what will
come up when it will be or of how you will do it in other words just trust him
beyond reason the Lord has told me to tell everybody to trust him beyond
reason in all the things that are happening today and will happen in the
future because we're living in the time of the great apostasy and the anti-Christ
is coming we have to learn how to trust the Lord absolutely so he's telling the
priest to trust him I myself will be there to assist you according to your
needs the Lord will never abandon any of us then Jesus added if you exercise
yourself in this faith almost swimming in it as recompense I will infuse three
spiritual joys into your heart first you will penetrate the things of God with
clarity now people whose faith is weak are not able to penetrate the things of
God at all and in doing holy things you will feel inundated with such
gladness with such joy as to feel as though soaked with it this is the
unction of my grace very special second you will feel boredom for earthly things
and you will feel joy in your heart for celestial things now that's one of the
things we need to check out because we're absolutely saturated by the world
through all our gadgets third total detachment from everything and there
there where you felt inclination in the past you will feel bothered this I have
been infusing in your heart for some time and you are already experiencing it
because of this your heart will be inundated with the joy which naked souls
enjoy and naked soul means that the clutter of the world is not there it's
gone who have their heart so inundated with my love that they're not affected at
all by the things that surround them externally what a wonderful place to
arrive at July the fourth 1899 Jesus speaks about disturbance you have to put
a VIP on this one because the first four volumes are the foundational volumes for
the divine will and Jesus makes sure that we are actually on our feet that we
are on the right path that we're doing the right things because if we jump into
the deeper lessons of the divine will and our feet are not in the right place we
won't just make it this morning Jesus renewed in me the pains of the crucifixion
our queen mother was present and Jesus speaking of her said my kingdom was in
the heart of my mother and this because her heart was never disturbed even slightly
so much so that in the immense sea of the passion she suffered immense pains
and her heart was pierced through by the sword of sorrow but she did not receive
the slightest breath of disturbance therefore since my kingdom is a kingdom
of peace I was able to lay my kingdom within her and to rain freely without any
obstacle now blessed mother is given to us as a model here as she is many times
in Luke 17 21 Jesus said the kingdom of God is within you at the beginning of
Luke's gospel in chapter 2 Jesus was announced as the prince of peace the one
who was to give peace to anyone of goodwill well that reigning king of peace
cannot reign in disturbance so we have to get all disturbance out of us that
disturbance tells us we're not trusting God beyond reason we're not laying down
our whole lives to him and so we have to get rid of this disturbance and let
that peace that passes all understanding which is Philippians 4 7 guard our
hearts and our minds in Christ Jesus Jesus kept coming other times and I
Louisa said seeing myself all full of sins said to him my Lord Jesus I feel I'm
all covered with wounds and with grave sins please I beg you have pity on this
miserable one and Jesus said do not fear for there are no grave sins you have to
understand that for someone to live in the divine will not only can you not
have grave sins you cannot have deliberate venial sins either there can be no sin
in you Hebrews 12 14 nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of God
it's actually that simple one John three two when we see Jesus we will be like him
when we see him as he really is and he says that those who are really like him
do not sin it's actually that simple do not fear there are no grave sins Jesus
said and besides one must have horror for sin but not become disturbed because
agitation wherever it comes from never does any good to the soul now please read
this ten times over and ask the Lord to enable you to take it on board then Jesus
added my daughter you are a victim soul as I am let all your works shine with the
same intentions as mine that means you do everything for the glory of God you do
everything for a love of Jesus you do everything to please him pure and holy
so that finding my own image in you that's Romans 829 I may pour the influence of
my grace is freely and I may offer you adorned in this way as a fragrant victim
before divine justice now if you know anything about the Old Testament system
of sacrifice an animal that was offered to God as a victim of sacrifice had to
be completely pure there's even the slightest mark on it it would not be
offered to God because it wasn't worthy of God the priest who was offering it had
to be pure not only that but he had to actually wash his body before the
sacrifice everything that he wore on his body had to be pure linen representing
absolute purity because only the pure in heart can see God that's Matthew 5 8 so
we just need to understand these things and therefore when we come into the
journey of divine will the Lord is going to do an enormous amount of
purification in us to make us able to walk this journey with him so July the
9th 1899 Jesus shares his pains with the soul in order to continue his
passion and his passion is to save souls to suffer in order to save souls so this
morning Jesus wanted to renew in me the pains of the crucifixion first he
transported me outside of myself up on a mountain and then he asked me whether I
wanted to be crucified and Louisa said yes my Jesus I yarn for nothing but the
cross and as I was saying this a huge cross appeared he laid me on it and
nailed me to it with his own hands that's not our image of Jesus what a
atrocious pains I suffered in feeling my hands and feet being pierced through by
these nails and what is more they did not have a point now Louisa says this also
in the hours of the passion that the nails that were driven into Jesus hands
and feet did not have a point and therefore as they were driven into his
hands and feet they crushed all the bones of course they did not have a point
she said and it was hard and very painful to make them penetrate but with Jesus
everything was tolerable that's Philippians 4 13 after he finished
crucifying me he told me my daughter I make use of you in order to continue my
passion since my glorified body can no longer be capable of suffering by coming
into you I make use of your body just as I use mine during my mortal life to be
able to continue and to suffer my passion and therefore to be able to offer
you as a living victim of reparation and propitiation before divine justice now
an offering of propitiation means to appease divine justice
zascalation 6 17 now what Jesus is saying here is that the days of his incarnation
are over therefore he cannot do this suffering himself but each one of us is
a member of the body of Christ so we have to participate in the sufferings of
Jesus because it's in the church now that the passion continues but there are
some members of the church that we call victim souls who excel in this area and
they are much more willing than the rest of us to actually suffer the actual
crucifixion and it may scandalize you to think that Jesus himself did it but
what he's doing is he's making Louisa an exact image of himself and therefore
giving her the extraordinary privilege of being a core edeemer and therefore
millions of souls will be saved because of this extraordinary gift that Louisa
has agreed to give to the Lord after this Louisa said heaven seemed to open
and a multitude of saints came down all armed with swords a voice like thunder
came from within the multitude a voice like thunder is very interesting if you
go to John chapter 12 and I'm not sure the verse at this moment it sounds like
verse 40 where when God spoke it sounded like a clap of thunder to the people
around Jesus so a voice like thunder came out from within the multitude saying
we come to defend the justice of God and to take revenge on human beings who
have so much abused God's mercy oh that's interesting isn't it so God has
been infinitely merciful to us through the incarnation life passion death and
resurrection of Jesus and if we have abused we meaning the human race have
abused God's mercy then we have called justice to balance the books okay now
when you go to the book of Revelation from chapter 6 onwards when you get the
terrible chastisements described there it is the angels who actually carry out
God's orders all the time so here you have the angels coming down as the agents
of God's justice but you also have a passage in the book of Revelation I think
it's around chapter 9 where the martyrs in heaven also asked the Lord to bring
justice to the earth as well so the Lisa says who can say what was happening on
earth at this descent of the saints I'm only able to say that some were fighting
in one place some in another some were fleeing and some were hiding it seemed
that they were all in dismay now you see if you follow the book of Revelation
when the angels come down they carry out the most dreadful chastisements and the
two great chastisements of the 20th century are the two world wars so July
the 14th 1899 Jesus cannot leave one who loves him these days
Louisa said my adorable Jesus continues to make him seen very few times his
visitors like a flash when one would want to keep looking he's already gone and
if sometimes he stays for a little while it's almost always in silence now that
silence always indicates that he's in a mood for justice and if he doesn't tell
Louisa what's going on then he's not letting her actually mitigate the
justice other times he says something but the moment he goes away he seems to
withdraw that word together with the light that comes from his word so much
so that afterwards I'm no longer a member anything of what he has said and
my mind remains in the same confusion as before what a miserable state I'm in
she said my dear Jesus have pity on this misery continue to make use of your
mercy so in order not to be too long saying what happened to me day by day I
will say now all at once a few words he told me in the past few days I
remember that after I had shed most bitter tears Jesus made himself seen and
since I lamented to him that he had left me he called many angels and saints to
himself as witnesses and turning to them he said listen to what she says that I
have left her tell her a little can I leave those who love me she has loved me
how can I leave her the saints were in agreement with the Lord and I remained
more humiliated and confused than before Louisa said another time after I said to
him in the end you know you'll give up you leave me completely and Jesus said
daughter I cannot leave you that's Joshua 1 5 I will never leave you or forsake
you okay you will also have Hebrews 13 5 I will never leave you or forsake you
John 14 18 I will not leave you comfortless okay but Louisa is always crying out
Sam 27 verse 9 don't leave me don't desert me Lord so I won't give you those
references all the time because they're repeated in almost every message okay
so now the saints and the angels agree with Jesus against Louisa so another time
he said daughter I can't leave you and as a pledge of this I've placed my
sufferings in you if I've shared the cross with you how could I possibly leave
you then while I was occupied with this thought how is it Lord that you have
permitted the coming of the confessor so that's the thorn in her side everything
could have passed between me and you in one instance I found myself she said
outside of myself lying on a cross and there was no one who could nail me to it
I began to pray the Lord to come and crucify me himself and Jesus came and
told me see how necessary it is for the priest to be in the middle of my works
he's trying to get Louisa to agree to something that he knows is necessary and
she thinks is just a nuisance you see that the priest is actually necessary and
this is also help in order to complete the crucifixion in other words she
needs an obedience from the priest indeed without anybody else you cannot
crucify yourself by yourself it always takes the help of others it would make
you smile it's always other people that crucify you whether that's emotionally
mentally or spiritually or physically so July the 18th 1899 how sacramental
Jesus and the soul draw and bind each other it continues always in the same
way this time it seemed that in my heart there was Jesus in the sacramental host
spreading many rays in my interior from the holy host many threads were coming
out of my heart which intertwined with all those rays of light it seemed to
me that Jesus with his love was drawing all of my heart to himself and my heart
with those threads was drawing and binding all of Jesus to remain with me
so this is called come union you and me and I in you which of course is John 14
20 to 21 and also Deuteronomy chapter 6 verses 4 to 10 so July the 22nd 18
99 how the cross renders the soul transparent okay now we're getting
teachings on the cross this morning my adorable Jesus made himself seen with the
golden cross all shining hanging from his neck and in looking at it he was
immensely pleased in one instant the confessor was present and Jesus said to
him the sufferings of these past days have increased the splendor of the cross
so much so that in looking at it I take great delight and then he turned to me
and he said the cross communicates such splendor to the soul as to render her
transparent now he's going to use the term crystal as well so that light
actually goes through crystal and the word transparent also a means spiritualized
you need to write that down spiritualized so that the heaviness of the flesh and
the world and all of that is gone and we become more and more and more spiritual
and therefore risen from the dead you see the cross comes before the resurrection
and the people who reject the cross are also rejecting the resurrection just as
one can can give all the colors he wants to an object which is transparent in the
same way with this light the cross provides all features and the most
beautiful shapes that can possibly be imagined not only by others but by the
very soul that experiences them furthermore on a transparent object one
can immediately detect dust little stains and even a shadow such is the cross since
the cross renders the soul transparent it immediately reveals to the soul the
little defects that at the beginning of our journey we don't give the slightest
attention to but as we go on in our closeness to God these little defects
have to be dealt with so it reveals to the soul the little defects and the
slightest imperfections so much so that there is no hand of a master more
capable than the cross in keeping the soul prepared to make of her a residence
worthy of the god of heaven so one Corinthians 3 16 where we become the
temple of God Louisa said who can say what I understood about the cross and how
enviable is the soul that possesses it after this Jesus transported me outside
of myself and I found myself at the top of a very high staircase so this is the
stairway to God do you remember Jacob seeing the stairway between heaven and
earth and the angels going up and down and John 151 that Jesus said he was the
fulfillment of Jacob's ladder she sees a very high staircase there was a
precipice under it and what is more the steps of this staircase were movable and
they were so narrow that one could barely put the tips of one's toes on it
what terrified me the most was the precipice she said and the fact that
one could find no support whatsoever and if one tried to cling to the steps they
would come out the sight of other people almost all of them falling made one's
bones shiver now this is a severe warning that's been given to us yet there was
no other way of going up this particular stairs so she said I tried and after I
did two or three steps in seeing the great danger for me of falling into the
abyss I started to call Jesus to come to my aid not knowing how I found Jesus
most to me and he said my daughter what you have seen is the path which all men
cover on this earth so this is the stairway to heaven okay the movable steps on
which they cannot even lean to find support are the human supports the
earthly things if one tries to lean on them instead of giving help they give
them a push and make them fall much more quickly into hell the safest means is
to climb almost flying without touching the ground by force of one's arms and
the eyes all fixed on oneself without looking at others and also by keeping
them all intent on me in order to receive help and strength now Jesus says first
of all put your head down and keep going don't look at other people don't look
back at the world this is a spiritual journey you put your eyes on the goal
lean on Jesus and go don't even think about it just go and go so fast that you
yourself won't even realize how fast you're going unfortunately most people
don't take that advice and they drag their heels all the way to Calvary so
July the 28th 1899 the cross is the noblest mark for the soul look how often
we are coming back to the cross absolutely essential this morning my
adorable Jesus came with an appearance all admirable and mysterious he was
wearing a chain at his neck hanging over his whole breast at one end of the chain
one could see something like a bow at the other end something like a quiver full
of precious stones and gems which formed an ornament of the most beautiful sort
on the breast of my sweet Jesus he also had a lance in his hands that's a lot of
armor while in disappearance he told me human life is a game some play pleasure
some play money some play with their own lives and many other games I too
delight in playing with souls that's Proverbs 8 31 the Lord delights to be
with the children of men but what are the games I make they are the crosses
which I send if they receive them with resignation and thank me for them I
enjoy myself and I play with them delighting immensely receiving great
honor and glory and letting them make the greatest gains now most people don't
think of the cross as a special birthday gift from Jesus as a special sign of his
love and that's exactly what he says and so if we accept the cross and resign
ourselves to it then he is able to work wonderfully in us as he was saying this
Jesus began to touch me with the lance all the precious stones that the bow and
the quiver contained came out and turned into many crosses and arrows which
wounded human beings some of them but extremely few rejoiced and kissed these
crosses and thanked the Lord engaging with the game with Jesus others then
would take them and would throw them in his face oh how afflicted Jesus would be
left and what a loss for these souls and then Jesus added this is the thirst
with which I cried out on the cross which unable to quench entirely at that time
I delight in continuing to quench in the souls of the dear ones who suffer so
when you suffer you come to give a refreshment to my thirst now this crying
out I thirst is in John 19 28 so when we accept suffering and the cross we are
giving Jesus the relief that he was looking for when he was on the cross and
he said I thirst in other words he thirsts for us to be identical with him
to live the same life to be core redeemers to save our brothers and
sisters okay on the earth and to love as he loved as Jesus came on other times
Louisa said I prayed him to free the confessor who was suffering and he told
me my daughter don't you know that the noblest mark I can impress on my dear
children is the cross so here's Louisa coming back to the Lord time and time and
time and time again asking him to heal the priest of whatever is wrong and
first of all he told her don't interfere with my just judgments and now he says
don't you realize it's a privilege to carry the cross so July the 30th 1899 do
not judge your neighbor this is Matthew 7 verses 1 to 5
Louisa says it continues almost always the same way this morning as Jesus
transported me outside of myself according to his usual way we passed
through the midst of many people and the majority of them were intent on judging
other people's actions without looking at their own you remember Jesus said take
the plank out of your own eye and don't be bothered about the dot in your
neighbor's eyes my beloved Jesus told me the surest means to be upright with one's
neighbor is to not look at all at what they are doing because looking thinking
and judging are all the same so the first teaching he gives us here is take your
eyes off what other people are doing keep your eyes on the Lord okay the second
thing he tells us is after this Louisa said I said to him my only good it has
been a while since you gave me even just a kiss and so we kissed each other then
almost wanting to correct me he added my daughter what I recommend to you is to
preserve and cherish my words because my word is eternal my word is as pure as I
am myself and by preserving it in your heart and profiting from it you will have
your sanctification and will receive an eternal splendor as recompense which is
produced by my word by doing otherwise your soul would receive a void and you
would remain my debtor now this is extremely important Jesus is almost on a
daily basis giving his word to Louisa which is given to us here in the 36
volumes and you've heard Louisa saying over and over again look I can say that I
leave it for now it would be too long and all the rest of it and Jesus begins to
try and tell her what an extraordinary privilege it is to be given his word
and that we should treasure his word like we would treasure the greatest thing
that we could possibly imagine there is one entire Sam given to the attributes
of the word of God and it's Sam 119 it has about 150 verses in it and it's all
about the power of God's word also I want to give you Isaiah 55 verses 10 and
11 my word is like the rain the Lord said and it goes down to the earth and it
fertilizes the earth and makes everything grow it never comes back to me empty now
throughout all of these volumes Jesus says over and over and over again that his
word is creative that when he pronounces his word it actually creates in us what
has been expressed so you'll hear Louisa saying this time after time yes I
received this I understood it and she meditates on it and Jesus is saying here
that you have to preserve the word in your heart and you have to profit by it
it's not just theory it's not just something to discuss it's something to
live the letter of Saint James chapter 5 is a chapter 5 or chapter 1 I can't
remember verses 22 to 25 tells us that I think is chapter 1 tells us that when
we have either listened to the word being proclaimed or we have read the word
we must not go away and forget about it the word has to be lived it's got to be
taken on board and lived I also want to give you Luke 21 33 very very important
message there on the word of God okay so July the 31st 1899 intellectual
communication between Jesus and the soul this is going to speak about infused
knowledge Jesus came also this morning though always in silence but I was very
content as long as I had my treasure Jesus because by having him I have all my
contentment in seeing him I understood many things about his beauty about his
goodness and about other things but since it was all through the intelligence and
by means of intellectual communication or infused knowledge my mouth is incapable
of expressing it and she's going to leave it like that but the Lord is going to
make her come back and deal with it at another point so August the first 1899
this is about purity purity is not a good word today nobody's interested in
purity we're living in a sexual revolution and the more you indulge the
better they like it people have forgotten about purity of the body and
modesty and clothes they have forgotten chastity and so when the eyes of our
mind are clouded with all this fog and all this stuff that they get into we're
no longer able to see God because only the pure in heart can see God so put
Matthew 5 8 there at the very top this morning my most gentle Jesus carrying
me outside of myself made me see the corruption into which mankind had fallen
it's horrifying to think about it now this was 1899 can you imagine what it's
like today in God's eyes while I was in the midst of these people almost crying
Jesus was saying oh man how you have disfigured deformed and disennobled
yourself oh man I made you so that you might be my living temple 1 Corinthians
3 16 but you've made yourself into the dwelling of the devil look even the
plants by being covered with leaves flowers and fruits teach you honesty and
teach you the modesty that you must have with your body but you having lost any
modesty and even the natural reserve that you should have have become worse
than the animals so much so that I have nothing else with which to compare you
you wear my image Genesis 2 7 and Genesis 1 27 you wear my image but now I no
longer recognize you even more I am so horrified at your impurities that the
mere sight of you nauseates me and you yourself force me to flee from you there
I want to give you have a cook 1 13 and this says Lord your eyes are too pure to
look upon evil while Jesus was saying this Luisa said I felt tortured with the
pain of seeing my beloved Jesus so embittered and so I said to him Lord you
are right that you find nothing good in man anymore and that he has reached
such blindness as to no longer be able even to keep the laws of nature that's
Isaiah 6 9 these people will see and see and never see they will hear and hear
and never hear because their hearts have become gross with sin and they have
blinded their eyes and deafened their ears for fear that they would be
converted and live man has reached such blindness as to no longer be able even
to keep the laws of nature so if you want to look at man you will be doing
nothing but sending chastisements therefore I pray you to keep your eyes on
your own mercy and in this way everything will be remedied and as I was
saying this Jesus said daughter give me your refreshment for my pains now giving
him a refreshment means you suffer to save souls in the act of saying this he
removed the crown of thorns which seemed to be sunken into his adorable head and
he drove them into mine Hebrews 12 - I felt most bitter pains but I was content
that Jesus was being refreshed after this he said daughter I greatly love pure
souls Matthew 5 8 and just as I am forced to flee from the impure I am
drawn by the pure as by a magnet to dwell in them Hebrews 12 14 to pure souls I
gladly lend my mouth to let them speak with my own tongue therefore they have
to make no effort to convert souls with these souls I delight not only in
continuing my passion within them and so continuing redemption with what is
more I greatly delight in glorifying my own virtues in them Romans 8 28 and
following so August the second 1899 how we respond to grace and to Jesus
invitations this morning my adorable Jesus made himself seen all afflicted
and almost angry with human beings threatening to send the usual chastisements
and to make people die suddenly under lightning's hail and fire I prayed him
very much to placate himself and Jesus told me the iniquities that rise from
the earth to heaven are so many that if prayer and souls who are victims before
me were missing for a quarter of an hour I would make fire come out of the earth
and inundate people that is almost unbelievable but I want to give you two
Peter 3 10 there then he added see how many graces I was supposed to pour over
human beings and since I find no response from them I am forced to hold them back
within myself even more they make me change them into chastisement be careful
you my daughter to respond to me and to respond to the many graces that I am
pouring into you because correspondence is the open door to let me enter into the
heart and form my residence in it my residence in it of course is one
Corinthians 3 16 okay and also John 14 23
correspondences like the good welcome that esteem which is used with people when
they come to visit us in such a way that drawn by that respect by those
affable manners used with them they are forced to come again and reach the point
of not being able to detach themselves everything is in responding to me and
according to how souls respond to me and treat me on the earth so I will behave
with them in heaven underlying that in green white and gold the Lord will treat
us in heaven in the same way as we have treated him on the earth making them find
doors open I will invite the whole celestial court to welcome them and I
will place them on the most sublime throne but it'll be all the opposite for
those who don't respond so I want to give you one Samuel 230 those who honor me I
will honor and I want to give you Revelation 2 and 3 and at the end of
each section there you're told exactly the prize with which the Lord will
honor those who have responded to his challenges so we leave it there for that
segment